the online gaming Market will increase
to 3.3 billion next year alongside that
fraud and addiction are rising too so in
many countries where gaming is allowed
regulation has begun to tighten because
both regulators and companies want to
protect people who struggle with a
serious Addiction in order for companies
to remain compliant we some sub created
a special solution responsible gaming
with specific rules configured for new
transaction types like gaming bets and
limit changes any potential gaming
issues are flagged we conduct thorough
checks on player transactions based on
the results transactions are assigned as
status companies can hold the power to
handle the monitoring results
safeguarding players well-being and
ensuring responsible gaming remains a
top priority stay compliant and stay
ahead of the responsible game